Yeah.
So,
um,
before I start my bow,
I will love to ask a few questions just to break the ice.
So when was the last time you got up at two o'clock to go to work.
All right.
None of you,
when was the last time you got scouted and to a chassis and late for work?
I don't think it exists in Google.
Right
then.
When was the last time you worked through Christmas Eve?
Christmas Day.
New Year Eve.
New Year day.
Okay.
Not Enough.
Yeah.
And,
and when was the last time you drove over eight hours.
How did that feel?
It sucks.
Right.
And have you tried parking it in emergencies on before?
All right.
We have on the law abiding citizens here.
And uh,
when was the last time you drove through snow and waned?
I did a was when was that
awesome.
Yeah.
I remember when I went to Vegas,
I drove through the Wayne and it was,
I thought I would die and I would never want it to do it again.
But unfortunately,
all of the above,
which we don't have experience with most of the time is our truck drivers life.
My name is Lydia and CEO and cofounder of next trucking.
We call it self,
the Fris trucker central market place where you would connect shippers with
small trucking companies,
own operator or small fleets.
Um,
we're actually a platform that connect a carriers with their preferred a loads
according to their own availabilities though the drivers can drive their
preferred a lotes.
And we start a company in October,
2015,
three years old.
Who are the revenue 100% a year ago,
a year and a this year were they looking at a three x our revenue?
Um,
we are a venture backed a company by a venture firms including sequoia capital
Brachfeld and it will raise the total off 105 $25 million as of today.
Okay.
So a lot of people without trucking is just the moving goods.
But I actually,
trucking is a huge industry and a 70% of Fred and the US is actually move on the
trucks and the trucking industry has five large segments,
full truck load less than a truck load.
Joe Age is moving into content there from the port to a local warehouse and
intermodal is putting the container on the rail and a small parcel.
So we focused on two segments.
One is pulling the container from the port to local warehouse and the second is
moving the goods from the local warehouse.
Two distribution centers like Amazon,
Walmart,
target,
et cetera.
The industry is cute but extremely fragmented.
Um,
90% of the trucking companies,
small ones,
most of them have less than six trucks.
Top 50 trucking companies,
only accounts for 16% of the market share.
The largest trucking company,
it only owns 12,000 trucks and is a $9 billion public company.
We have two huge problems in the industry.
One is lack of transparency and no technology.
It's an antiquated industry driver rely on brokers to find them loads.
We have phone calls,
text messages,
emails,
sometimes even facts.
It's ridiculous.
I know that and a lot of back and forth negotiations.
Drivers' wants certain loads because they're human beings and a shipper wants
certain lanes to be covered and they wanted to come to an agreement.
It's v a lot involves a lot of phone calls.
So the second is our industry's number one problem is trucker shortage.
I would industry is lack of released 100,000 truck drivers turnover rate 97%
which means every single trucking company needs to change their whole fleet once
a year.
Nobody wants to be a truck driver.
It's a tough lifestyle.
I imagine the other bullet points before that,
you don't want that.
And the the turnover,
that's creates a turnover rate and the also tremors don't get paid that well.
Average truck driver make about $45,000 a year.
Super tough lifestyle.
And a,
another thing that really costs a turn in the truck drivers is really,
we call forced dispatching.
I live in La,
I took a load to Arizona,
I wanted to go home.
I call all my brokers looking for a back haul.
People give me either low to New York or somewhere else,
nobody can bring me home.
So as a truck driver,
I only have two options.
One,
I backed her home,
basically a hot,
an empty trailer,
I'll lose money or I go to another state.
I'm mind needs to celebrate my daughter's first day,
but too bad I cannot find a bug,
a back haul.
So that's how we create a next trucking,
the first fucker center of marketplace where we design a solution really for
truck drivers and we allow them to come back to with shippers.
For the shipper side,
we allow sure press to access to a large massive database of virtual fleet.
In southern California,
we actually different from a lot of tech startups that are trying to spread the
world.
Where we are trying to do is really,
we call it building the lengths.
It's a marketplace.
You want it to make sure your supply meets demand and it's a very fragmented
market.
So when we did is we started with southern California.
We viewed a lot of local capacities and we built lanes,
which means we bring trucks from southern California to northern California to
Arizona,
Texas and Nevada.
So those are the cooling's we viewed.
And also we launched shippers to track and trace the drivers.
Real time.
Google map is so advanced it,
but too bad shippers never know to driver is even till today.
Shippers called broker broker called trucker and ask for the chocolate or
location,
then communicate back to the shipper.
Tons of back and forth negotiations.
And the communication is sometimes drivers may lie,
brokers may lie,
right?
So there's really no transparency in that.
And also we provide our shippers real time proof of delivery.
It's a little piece of paper.
It was driver's signature and received receivers signature on it,
proving that the load is too the vert.
But in the past or even today,
brokers need to call driver drama.
Bring that piece of paper back to the broker's office,
getting the payment and a broker scan that piece of paper and send to shipper.
Then they will collect the money.
She grew up collect money from the buyers,
but the whole process takes two to four weeks,
which means as a shipper,
my merchandise got delivered.
I cannot even bill my buyer after four weeks.
Huge cashflow issues for a lot of shippers.
So without solution,
every everything is online.
Everything is.
They just whole lysed.
So shipper can build the buyers the moment the loads get delivered.
And of course we provide EDI and API solution.
Of course a lot.
I remember when I was pitching sequoia capital,
I say we're Edi and API ready.
They were like,
what is Edi?
I remember one of the senior partners that,
oh,
that was technology from 20 years ago.
We actually invest in one of those companies,
but too bad we still use this in trucking industry today.
So far on the carrier side,
we provide predictive load offering capability.
So basically we studied driver's behavior,
their own preferences,
the availabilities,
so we can predict the kind of loads that we want it to give to the shippers.
So they don't need to call,
they don't need to negotiate whatever we give to them.
They will accept.
So actually we reduced the time that they spend on negotiating with traditional
brokers.
On top of that,
I would provide fuel events,
quick pay and offer a very lightweight web based,
the fleet management software.
And of course I'm top of that and we have walkie talkies on the APP.
They can communicate with other drivers,
really trying to create a community feeling for our drivers in a different from
other texts.
Olives,
as I mentioned,
we are port focused,
we're original focus.
La is the largest port of the whole country.
40% of our merchandise this in this country are important and 30% of them come
into La and Long Beach Port La Represent 15 I'm sorry,
this year is 17 t years.
So Teu is 20 equivalent unit.
So it's really a metrics.
We measure how many containers that coming in.
So average content is about 40 footers,
so 20 is like half of containers.
So we're looking at about 8.5 million contenders coming into this point and the
La along is $14 billion shipping business,
so we don't need to even go out to bid on Montebello.
Ended all company here.
We created this really program last year.
It's the,
we call it a different kind of dre edge,
so I'm not going to go into the details of this,
but with this solution,
it's actually a combination of our virtual fleet asset and marketplace and allow
us to inject additional capacity to drayage and increase of trans I'm trucks in
the terminals.
So for our drainage relay drivers,
they on average make 20% more money.
Not necessarily pay them more,
but they are more efficient because right now 40% of a capacity is wasted.
And that would go and ambition is really to go to every single port in the US
and the really give the best solution to the port to reduce the congestion at
the terminals to bring in freight and morph a lot faster.
And it makes sure the merchandise moves a lot faster.
Shippers will increase the cash flow
and why we do this and do what we do.
So a lot of people wanting to start up a company because they see the problems.
But a lot of them start a company because they saw the bus ward like blockchain,
right?
Like AI and people just want to apply technology and something.
But we are doing,
this is really for a cost.
So this is a real story.
Kevin Luke is one of our own operators.
I wanted to give you a little bit background of him.
He had a little smaller business a couple years ago.
It's a tax business and he failed miserably and he actually filed a bankruptcy.
He and his wife live on the street,
so he worked for a trucking company going into the terminal every single day.
He really worked hard to save up.
So the moment he saved up a little money to be able to pay for the down payment
for a truck,
he bought his first truck.
He wanted to be an entrepreneur,
so he became own operator.
He went to the terminal every single day.
He worked so many hours a day,
but still he could barely survive.
He found us last year.
And a,
the reason why we found about this story is he came to our office for the mobile
2.0 focus grip and the,
he shared his personal story and he broke down during the focus group.
I wanted to share this video with you.
I got into trucking,
all grandfather was dying from cancer and he kind of passed the torch to me when
I was homeless.
It was duck toughest thing I ever could have been through.
I was actually sleeping in,
uh,
a guy truck.
I was driving,
I,
me and my wife.
So she used to up your wait till I got off 18 hours to get in the bed,
but you pushed through something like that.
What could stop
working for next?
Changed my life dramatically far has given me a lot of time back to spend time
with the family,
uh,
double my income,
allowing me to grow my business to another level,
uh,
faster than what I expected.
So,
um,
so I always told my team because of stories like this,
it's emotional,
it's beautiful,
and we're not just building a mobile app.
We're changing people's life.
It's bigger than what we thought it is.
And also this kept us going and a cap us moving forward because we are literally
changing truck driver's life and a lot of people ask me,
Lydia,
why now?
Why didn't you come up with this solution 10 years ago?
Trucking never change.
And then passed the centuries.
Who fucking never changed?
It was like that in the past 24 years.
But logistics was not that important 10 years ago.
I remember 10 years ago,
because my husband has been logistics for a long time and I was actually talking
to some investors,
wanted to raise some money for his small logistics company.
Nobody wanted to talk to us 10 years ago because of the logistics was not sexy
enough.
It's not tech enough.
It's not cool enough.
But 10 years ago,
international trading companies had thick margins.
So logistic cost is really a fraction of their margin,
but it was the growth of ecommerce and the transparency of the world.
Now it becomes very,
very transparent.
So vendors,
the margin actually decrease the dramatically.
While logistics costs increased that dramatically.
Right now,
let's just the cost accounts for 10% off an average vendors margin.
So it become very,
very important.
So now all of a sudden Anna was looking into logistics,
see how we can be more efficient,
how we can save money there.
That's why in the past three years,
millions of dollars got poured into logistics space and according to some youth
and estimate that US companies is going to spend more than two point $5 billion
in disruptive logistics and supply chain technology by 20 2022 and the overall
supply chain logistic tax banding will rise to 87 billon dollars.
So everyone's trying to create a solution to make free shipping painless.
And also there's the fundamental issue with the industry is there's an imbalance
between supply and demand,
right?
We have a lot of freight to move.
I know how many of you purchase on Amazon every single month,
right?
But nowadays what are,
we don't have enough truck drivers.
I would,
truck drivers are not efficient enough,
but they are the fondant foundation of our economy.
So the goal is really to attract capacity back to the industry.
I will average truck drivers ages over 50 so after 10 years,
what do we do?
Do we have enough trucks?
How can we move the goods?
So that's the problem that companies like us,
Uber Freight,
convoy,
everyone's trying to resolve the problem from different angles.
So people talk about future,
what are we seeing in the future?
We believe companies like us will replace the traditional brokage technology
platform to really connect.
The shipper was care where it's more efficiently.
And other than that we're looking at to play years really in the trucking space.
One is clean trucks cause carbon emission is re really big problems in the,
especially for the age companies and all the port's really required cling
trucks.
So claim trucking companies like Tesla or Uid in China and also hydrogen
companies like Nicola.
There will be playing major roles in local drayage autonomous is really getting
Dick and uh,
who have a Tesla here.
All right,
who knows way more.
Yes.
So this is really the future.
And companies like startups like to simple Starsky embark in a Google is way
more by do.
Paccar.
Everyone's really looking to autonomous trucks because driving is really a
painful experience for truck drivers,
especially for long haul drivers.
Traditional truck manufacturers like Volvo,
Toyota,
BMW,
Volkswagen.
I know Mercedes have the most expensive autonomous trucks for the,
everyone is looking into the space.
So this is what we think that will happen in five years,
not 10 years,
five years.
So for local trucks we will see a lot of electronic or hydrogen trucks to really
create low emission,
um,
transportation methods.
So it's really from the local warehouse to a yard there in front of the yard,
then to out of state warehouse,
it will go on and,
and Thomas Truck,
because it can really eliminate the burden for the drivers driving long hours
and allow drivers to really only manage exceptions.
Then when the loads are arriving at the local city,
which is a destination,
we'll,
we'll have another local truck that pickup the loads from the yard,
then move to local warehouse.
I predict it will happen in five years and it might be shorter than we expect.
All right.
So my name's Lydia and um,
I was born in Shanghai,
China.
So I'm a pure immigrant.
I was the only child,
um,
same as the most,
the people that were born after 1978.
Um,
so I do have some single child,
uh,
symptoms.
Um,
very selfish,
but the best,
the thing is I was really just center of the university,
my family,
and,
and got the best education because education is very important to Chinese
families.
I went to a school called Shanghai foreign languages school where I met.
I met my first American teacher who actually inspired me to come to this country
to pursue my master's degree because I love the freedom that she brought to us.
I,
she,
she brought the best of classes.
So after graduating from college in China,
I apply for a master's degree in the US.
I applied for several universities and uh,
got accepted by most of them.
I chose to go to Uva because of the ranking.
I really have no idea what the map looks like.
So I'm in awful.
Uva actually gave me a teaching assistant scholarship.
Back then.
It was very hard for a Chinese citizen to come to this country study,
especially when you don't have scholarship,
so I have to get scholarship.
So I applied for Italian literature.
I did study Italian and in I got an Italian literature,
um,
teaching assistant scholarship,
which means I had to teach 80 students in Italian,
which is pretty weird for Chinese to teaching Americans Italian,
but it happened to me,
but I really appreciate it my two semesters that Uva because I actually left
after two semesters because I know that I wouldn't want it to be a professor as
a Korea,
but I really got experience as a coaching.
I really got my coaching skills there and I was not afraid of standing on the
stage and speak to the people because I got 80 students down there and ask me
questions all the time and I was less nervous,
a lot more brave and I dare to raise my hand and it questions.
I really appreciate that.
That's what I learned from Uva and after then I transferred to USC,
pursue my master's degree in communications management because I wanted to be a
journalist.
But obviously it was very hard and my English wasn't even good enough back then.
Even it nowadays it's not the best English.
Then,
um,
after graduation,
obviously couldn't find a job as a journalist.
So I found a job at the,
an ad agency as an account executives.
So job was really talked to the show,
a lot of clients and negotiate contract.
I actually practice my negotiation skills for my first job back then.
And uh,
who,
who's,
who's not good at negotiating chance here?
Alright.
If you're not very good at it,
I recommend a book.
Never split the difference by Chris Voss.
He was actually a former FPI um,
negotiator for hostage and I,
this book,
it was actually in today's dividing my a sequoia partner.
Oh my homeboy.
He was the founder off ad mob.
He gave me the book,
then I read it,
I was inspired and he regretted it because I negotiated with him.
But uh,
yeah,
if you have interested can read this.
It's actually a very interesting book and that's available.
I'm as Amazon and the audio as well.
And after that I started because I was wanting to be an entrepreneur.
I started a few small companies.
I fell to all of them and failed miserably.
The more memorable one was the one I started in China.
Come Nigh,
look,
see it's a flash sale website.
Very similar to guilt because I was really inspired about it.
Guilt,
guilt was really big back then.
So I went there really bravely and abroad,
borrowed the money from my family,
started this little company,
was five people and the my margin was 75% I was selling us merchandises.
I was the first one who brought juicy couture back to China and uh,
the company was profitable after six months.
I was so happy,
but I forgot one thing.
China is competitive.
After few months,
hundreds of flash sale website,
Kim up,
everybody would raise tons of money.
Nobody wants to make them any money.
I got squeezed out just six months later I got flushed out.
So lesson learned,
there is two things.
Speed is the only competitive advantage.
No matter how good your technology is,
you need to move fast.
No matter how good your team is,
Second,
you need to learn.
If you want it to be in tech,
you need to make sure your company has money.
Fundraising is probably a virtual for a founder.
So learning how to raise money is important.
So here comes the origin and inspirations from next tracking.
It's really from two stories I had because of my background.
I want it to be a journalist,
right?
I never was interesting logistics.
So unsexy sake,
an old man's and big guys and he's 180 pounds or 200 pounds,
so it's very boring to me.
But my husband has been in logistics for 15 years.
So the other day I went to his office,
he actually come pain every single day.
It's like I hate logistics.
Like why are you still in it?
But I hate it.
So I went to his office.
It was chaotic.
Everyone's fighting the dredge.
The drivers were fighting,
that's dispatchers were fighting.
I remember I sat next to a dispatcher,
he spent two hours trying to cover one load.
He pick up the phone,
call five drivers,
trying to find the cheapest one.
He found the cheapest one.
He give low to him and he,
he thought I probably can find another cheaper one.
So he caught two more.
Unfortunately he couldn't find a cheaper one,
went back to the other one and the driver dropped the load.
So he has to do all over again the bail and he's trying to lock another driver
two hours for low.
Well note,
extremely inefficient.
I find it a pretty amazing,
and a second story is we will actually driving on the freeway the other night
after party,
me and my husband.
So that was a midnight.
So we saw a big rig parking in emergencies zone.
So I was like,
I asked my husband,
I was like,
is he broken down?
Like why is he parking there and he's going to get a ticket.
So my husband was like,
he probably doesn't want to pay $25 truck stop parking fee.
I was shocked.
Those guys worked day and night.
They make Solado and they have to risk their life by parking in an emergency
zone.
Trying to save 25 bucks.
So that really inspired me.
I wanted to do something for them because I see those guys almost every single
day.
They work hard.
They are humble people.
They'd probably not the most sophisticated people,
but they deserve more.
So that's where we come up with inspirations just to help them.
Then we started to understand market and trying to identify where the root
causes.
So here come the ideation.
That's how my process was.
Just a four year in reference.
I interviewed a hundred truck drivers before I came up with this idea and uh,
I got understood their pinpoint,
they share their ideas with me.
I'd be at my first time meeting in three months
and it didn't work.
I,
when we launched the APP in October,
2015 I remember we had 30 users and our idea was like,
okay,
dry,
why don't we write us driving to dictate what they want so they can post their
truck.
So we actually created this post,
the truck function on the APP,
but too bad nobody posts truck.
Everyone download the APP asking for loads because their behavior is what do you
have?
Let me choose.
So we immediately clay and he changed.
The idea was switch the gear and say,
okay,
why don't we do this?
Let's post the loads and let them pick.
And then also we need to be really regional focus.
Why?
Because it's such a huge market.
If I onboarding drivers and New York,
I don't have your loads for them,
they're going to churn and by Amore shippers who want to ship on the lanes,
I don't have drivers,
my ship reward turn.
So then we actually scaled down to really beauty lanes.
Southern California only,
let's onboard southern California home based the drivers.
They had behaviors.
Very simple either I'm local,
I go out,
I come back.
So when we pitched shippers,
we do the exact same thing.
We're very good with those lengths.
We have a lot of drivers give those to us.
That's how we really create the matching and the really kept the marketplace
going.
So that's how we evolved.
Tested idea,
learn from our customers.
So a lot of people asking me,
he's like,
Lydia,
your background is pretty weak.
I was of course,
look at this.
It's the worst,
the package for a thought of founder,
right?
I'm an immigrant.
I'm a woman in trucking and I'd get an graduate from Google.
I didn't go to Stanford.
So pretty,
it's like I caught his beautiful irrelevant to silicone valley.
Um,
so it actually took me four months to raise my series day because nobody
believed in me.
Me,
like a lot of vcs ask me,
Lydia,
do you drive a truck?
It was like,
too bad.
I'm too short for that.
Um,
but that's how he started.
And,
uh,
I think there's something in me that kept me going and I wanted to share it with
you if you decide to be a founder.
One day is some strengths that I have.
If you are an average founder like me,
of course you are all graduate from your,
uh,
from Google.
So you do have the one element that's silly.
Cavalli he's looking for.
So,
um,
one trace,
I think I really get as I do have self awareness.
I know my weaknesses,
I know what I'm not good at.
So that's why I wanted to surround myself with the people who have to qualities
I don't have.
So I know I'm not a coder and I'm not a good people manager and I'm probably not
good at communicating ideas.
So I actually co really surrounded myself and Brian the team who are good in
those areas,
who can deliver the message better for me,
who can really be this an awesome product.
And of course I sell all the time,
not only to my customers,
I sell to the employees as well.
And I'm very scrappy at the very beginning.
We work on folding tables.
I don't know people always talk about garage or even worse,
we don't even have a graduate of folding tables.
Um,
I remember one employee,
actually one of my early point came in.
He actually worked on like folding table the first day and the second,
the way I shouldn't took it away because a,
we have one more person.
So he actually,
he had,
he worked on his labs.
So,
um,
we were very scrappy,
but we shared a one vision and we really wanted to change the truck driver's
life fundamentally.
So it's important to bring the people that share the vision was shared
mentality,
who equally scrappy as yeah.
At the very beginning and be patient.
I was very patient.
We made a lot of mistakes,
but I never gave up.
Even when at the very difficult.
Tommy in I think is the end of 2016 when I was reading series,
say we did $11 million first a year for his text object.
It's huge already.
I think we did a great job.
I was very confident when I walked out and went to silicon valley investors.
I got turned down by over 50 investors in literally a few weeks.
It was very disappointing to me.
And uh,
I think after 50 pictures you actually Polish the pitch a little bit better and
your skin grew a little bit thicker.
So,
um,
I didn't give up because at the end of day you've probably only need one.
Yes.
So at the end of 2016 we closed our series day was a Chinese investor called
China credit grip,
whereas a $5 million,
very small money.
And then we kept the growing.
Everybody wore multiple hats.
We worked tirelessly,
uh,
extremely hard.
Um,
I remember during the peak seasons,
everyone works over 12 hours a day.
And then we got a track.
We got really a lot of tractions from silicone valley.
We pick sequoia as our series B investor.
Of course,
the vast investor we can ask for and for secrecy.
And Larry took us 30 days to close a almost a hundred million dollar round.
We only wanted to raise $50 million,
but,
and we ended up actually a raising $97 million and we got Brookfield Onno book
and they're a fantastic strategic investor.
So I think another [inaudible] that have his hustle and ask for help.
When I just to start a company,
I didn't know any vcs.
I literally add every single person that I can possibly find on linkedin.
And I asked for introductions from the people that I don't even know.
That's how I got my first investor.
And then,
um,
I also got all the La founders contacts.
I basically message them and say,
Hey,
I want it to get a coffee with you.
And I wanted to know how you really bring up your company,
what challenges you have,
can you share some experiences with me?
So I made a very,
a group of good friends and who can share experiences with you and of course,
south south,
south,
south to the investors,
sell to the market and sell to your employees.
And one last thing I wanted to mention is company culture is very important.
I know Google has fantastic company cultures,
but for first time founders it's hard to define your company countries.
I didn't even know what it is.
Um,
I remember I went to a sequoia base camp and I was on a car with Scott Cook who
is the founder of intuit.
So I asked,
Kim was like,
Hey,
what is your company culture?
How did you define it?
He gave me one word.
He's like,
you are your company culture.
I was like,
how?
What does that mean?
He's like,
you know,
you and your leadership team really defined what a company is.
So after that we actually spend a lot of time trying to form it.
Cultural Committee tried to really come up with our mission,
vision and value and this is our first draft and we know it's going to involve.
So a mission is empowering drivers to work the way they want when they want and
the vision is painless freight.
We want to to acknowledge that free shipping is really painful and we're really
not resolving a rocket science issues.
We are really trying to make the their life a little bit better one step at a
time.
So five values and we have is put the drivers first.
It's very simple to a lot of tech companies basically put your users first at
demonstrate hustle,
passion two way.
I think I'm a very aggressive person even though I'm pretty small,
but I think it carries towards the whole company.
Everyone's very aggressive and we want you to solve a problem,
not symptoms.
This is actually something that most of you will see if you have a company
because of their very beginning.
Everybody was trying to put out fires.
We actually last year spent tons of time trying to putting out fires and we
didn't really look into root costs.
So this is something that we know we made a mistake and we wanted to change that
set and followed true north because especially when you have a business there,
lot of destructions just for us,
you know,
we want it to new dre edge,
but we got business full logistics,
other segments where to housing transloading there was a Jew revenues.
This is a real dollars.
Do we want to do this business?
Do we want to sacrifice it?
If you said the true north,
you know,
this is direction you want it to go and you do not want to be distracted.
So it's important you follow that.
And the trust that it seemed a good hands.
Um,
we default to trust that we bring the best to people and that the people will
take the ownership.
So my final words,
recommendations for a first time founder,
if you ever plan to be one,
just to really summarize what I just repeated,
uh,
set myself first is understand market.
And the size,
the dynamic identified a province.
Don't start a company because you think it's fancy,
it's sexy.
And there's a bus ward out there and blockchain and it probably doesn't work
right now for trucking and the tested ideas.
Be Brave to share the ideas.
It's okay.
Nobody can steal it.
If you can execute very well.
Learn from your customers.
We put ourself in Linwood.
It's not like the beautiful van is beach.
She has a Santa Monica.
We're in the ghetto.
And I remember some investor talk to me and I said,
always your office because they are coming to visit us.
I was like,
oh,
we're in the Gat or just be aware.
Okay.
And they can be in the video.
No joke.
You're straight outta Compton.
So we're literally like north of content.
Um,
but we're close to our users were literally next how truck drivers.
So we can talk to them on a daily basis and uh,
um,
be scrappy.
The very beginning,
unless you were multimillionaires,
you cannot afford to build a large team,
the best team.
You probably need to be scrappy.
It probably wanted to do everything yourself and be patient and never give up
and it's easy to give up,
but you know you will have the light at the end of the tunnel.
It will keep you moving and the work extremely hard.
This is no brainer.
You just have to enter your founder Hassan,
ask for help.
Don't be shy.
It's okay to ask for help.
They are a lot of founders like us and when we started and we didn't know what
to do and,
and we always were willing to share experience because we walked the road.
We know how difficult it is and a defined company conscious early.
That's the mistake that most companies make.
I did too.
I didn't really know my company conscious and we just push forward,
drive the revenues,
make the APP work and the Butte internal efficiencies,
but that we didn't know what our company conscious stillness here last as a
founder,
I was to be your best salesman,
salesman for your team sales man,
for your culture and sales man for your company vision.
Well,
thank you so much for your time.